guys and we're back here at the GameSpot
stage live at e3 2014 I'm Sean
McGuinness your host for the morning I'm
joined by Mike Michael and burns some of
the guys from a Dead Island 2 guys day
being with that trailer the other day
the dead island franchise obviously has
a history with very very dramatic very
exciting trailers yeah and it's kind of
like it's always an opportunity to show
off what you're aiming to do with the
game try to establish a certain tone a
certain look what were you guys trying
to convey with this trailer well I think
the most important thing for us is as
you said it's a it's a really big change
in tone for the last trailer the first
trailer was amazing and it set a really
great tone a narrative zone right it was
really important for us to set that the
new tone and the new direction in this
trailer and just get everybody on board
with our and deep Silver's new vision
for for this franchise did you say
ambition yeah yes we're on stage it's
okay just say vision yeah the thing what
we're aiming for is you know we're all
gamers and we didn't work on the first
game and I think we were in the same
boat like everyone you know this amazing
trailer came out of nowhere and then
somebody said hey look you have to watch
that trailer and I watched it I said oh
my god take my money I'm gonna it turned
out that the game was slightly different
but still really really really good but
there was a slight disconnect between
you know the tone assumptions in the
trailer and what the game portrayed to
be and when we sat down and started
thinking about what movie are we gonna
do with that Island - he said you know
what everything has to set the tone
right from the start to setting the
trailer the characters everything and
that's why we decided to go for
something that is more fun fun humorous
alright it's cool so if you guys have
any questions for these guys here feel
free to send them my way in the live
GameSpot chat beneath the video player
or you can tweet me questions I'm at s
McInnis on Twitter now obviously from
that trailer I gather Venice Beach yeah
in the Los Angeles area is sort of a
setting for the game is that correct
yeah for sure I mean we're trying to
we're trying to best represent
California as as everybody would imagine
it but
in Europe would imagine it on a postcard
it's the setting that everyone goes for
so he went for the most the most
picturesque them probably the most
bought postcard in California from
tourists and we just thought that would
be the best setting again to say this is
where we are this is the tone and it
just feeds into that with the color and
the vibrancy it's a yeah the most fun we
could get from Italy it's kind of like
when you google California
yeah and take the first five pictures
and that's it sure now at what point did
you guys decide it was okay to go at
California because technically not an
island I technically not there's a
couple of really oh you you really know
the answer I've already answered do you
want to are you gonna tell me that
California is culturally an island no it
was people can Wikipedia this now so
they couldn't they can start going but
no Wikipedia this and actually the
Spanish were the first people to get
there they saw the the land coming away
they Spanish actually put it down as an
island for a good 78 years or so in the
17th century
that's the lame Wikipedia answer the
answer that we've got in our in our
fiction of course is that California has
been completely separated from the rest
of America this point because the virus
has spread from Hanoi in the first games
it's made its way to the mainland let's
say and in response to that they've they
sectioned it off they've effectively
made an island out of California it's an
island in the sea off dead yeah okay so
a metaphorical island I can buy that
that's fine I'm totally on board
don't your own hey we're good so the
original Dead Island obviously one of
those games was very well known for
blending first-person action a very deep
RPG systems what how are you guys
looking to pick that up and move that
combination forward nope you go well no
obviously it was one of the the biggest
things that we all loved about it oh
yeah ger and we just thought what would
be how can we open that further what's
gonna serve us really well like one of
the best things about again going back
to California was that whole the kind of
survival RPG nests and having all the
opportunity to level up and go in
California the setting just gives us so
much more variety for that when we get
to when you're in binoy and you've got
all like the improvised weapons around
you've got your paddles and you can
level those up
Southern California we've got so many
more opportunities for that because
suddenly
you've got you know you've got your
giant department stores you've got your
garage for the power tools and things
like that so we can really just using
california-based expand on all of those
elements we get so much wealth from it
it's it's been really great one of the
questions that we've been getting here
on Twitter is about Yeager's history as
a development studio obviously it's on
the surface it seems like quite a
departure going from SpecOps the line
yeah that's a Dead Island too and I feel
like even if they're two very different
types of games I'm sure you always learn
something here and there from previous
projects that you carry forward is there
any sort of like you know what did you
guys learn from that game that you want
to bring forward here I think that one
thing that Yaeger brings to every game
that we make is a consistency that we
think really long and hard about what is
right and what is not what fits and an
inspector Upsilon there was a very
serious tone and now it's supposed to be
fun to play and like like a holiday in
paradise in the most iconic place on
earth California and I think that one
thing that we bring to the table said we
think really long and hard about
everything we put into the game like
what classes what genders we have in the
game other zombies diverse enough that
was a really long discussion we had you
know we have the rice split in ethnicity
and gender and everything else and our
zombies thank you not yes
discussions for weeks about that with
people saying no I'm not working on this
there has to be a spending Sami in the
game or and quit yeah that's the place
you ingress all right and also we were
quite tired of sand right so don't spend
too much time on Venice Beach move it
inland what you're saying
Maj wood in the GameSpot chat is asking
as a new person to this series how how
are they going to get adjusted to it do
they need to have played earlier games
in the franchise how are you going to
make sure that it's welcoming to
somebody who might not be familiar with
the story it's the same universe so it
shares some things like the background
the universe the the playful nature of
things but it's not a narrative sequel
so it starts fresh new heroes new
occasion new weapons new enemies all
brand new so you don't have to play them
what we hope is that you know people
still played a ton and one yeah if you
go on Xbox Live they play we do that a
lot you know for reference if you do
something everything hey wait a minute
how I said in the original game it's
almost impossible to play without
somebody dropping into your game yeah
and so it's really cool psiphon inch an
answer actually is iPhone in the chat is
asking about vehicles because you know
California especially Los Angeles in
particular it's one of those places
where it's impossible not to own a
vehicle and they're gonna I'm sure
there's gonna be plenty of them around
how do those feature into the game
compared to earlier ones well see we
really that was a great thing to be able
to do again coming to the US we suddenly
have this wealth of American car
heritage to dive into and that's that's
so much fun we've got we've got a really
talented group of guys one and a little
guy in particular work at Yeager on
those side of cars he's a great car fan
but he was so excited to get involved
with the the American cars and it's
something that we bring into each class
as well so each classes can have a
specialized version of a real solid
American car and we've we just really
want to expand that into the RPG of the
game and it's something again we really
want people to play and I would really
love people to come just see more of
that before I go too deep we have toy
vehicles so any points yeah every class
has their own vehicles which personality
you know the Joker you can imagine what
kind of a car is good for you know like
big bulky you beefy guy but we also have
toy vehicles and my current favorite is
the little remote-control car no no the
the little one with a golf cart all the
golf cart yes my current favorite yeah
you can't do California valve golf
course at all so all right pop you on
the game swatch at is asking about the
combat system the original Dead Island
featured an alternate control input for
analog based swings where you could like
swing the analog stick around to kind of
control your direction are you guys
doing anything like that
what's the control scheme like no we
have just one yeah just one
yeah just one so how would you describe
it then yeah
I wouldn't ascribe that it's really good
all right it's a trigger-based it's a
trigger base yeah we actually played
around with an analog system like
controlling hands and everything but
that fell to much less work it's tough
to get right you have to really want to
play the game that way because it's such
a huge there's some things that you can
just naturally get into with with either
buttons or a trigger system these kind
of like more natural combinations and
start feeling a rhythm out for the
combat yeah that's that's one of the
most rewarding things about it I mean
analog system hey they're great for the
right game sure right absolutely and and
with that analog system it was great
when I was i I played that way in the
first game and it was great when I was
taking on one or two zombies but when a
horde of 10 or 12 was coming after me I
jumped into the option switch to the
standard one because it was just there's
too much to get fast you just get fast
with them yeah oh man a lot of questions
here about hard question there's too
many questions to actually see it's a
good thing right
alright here we go question will you be
adding a customization element to cars
ie mounted guns belated Wheels anything
like that that sounds super exciting I
know guy back at Yaga who would
definitely agree with it and I would
like that person to come see it at PAX
later this year oh it's kind of
marketing yes yes part of a marketing
yes okay and invite to come play the
games all right well it's better than a
we're not ready to talk about that right
now kind of that's the marketing maybe
alright let's see here so the class
system is it you more or less kind of
the same thing you have you you choose
from four different characters you have
four different abilities yeah definitely
so we've got the the four player classes
we've got that you correct me and if I
mess up the names when we got the the
speeder and the speeder lady she is a
very fast and very nimble with bladed
weapons we've got the Huntress another
lovely lady and she is more of a range
specialist so she can help you out with
the crossbows or
firearms that kind of thing we've got
the Berserker there's a big strong
fireman sledge hammer wielding dude he's
your tank class he's your area magley
yeah like just like that and he's the
guy you're gonna want with your 12
zombies those kind of scenarios and then
we've got our support with it which is
the bishop and he's the guy you're gonna
go to for healing he's gonna be doing
like very like big area damage effects
and things like that so we keep the same
class structure as Dead Island and keep
it within the realm of making sure that
there's a clear role for everybody to
play and just different ways to interact
with a zombies in each other so all
right cool guys thank you so much for
joining me on the stage here any ideas
yet when you're planning to release the
game sorry any idea yet when you're
planning to remain 2015 spring 2015 yeah
sounds good wait yeah
come to pax check us out all right guys
you you heard them come to pax check it
out so there that was it that was Dead
Island 2 we're gonna get